at this dog shelter in southern Spain
they look after Greyhounds that have
been abandoned often they're badly
injured
for the people who work here it's a
labor of love so you'd think they'd be
in favor of a new law meant to
strengthen animal rights you'd be wrong
recently we were hit by a big setback
suddenly there was an amendment where
hunting animals among other animals such
as work animals would not be covered by
this law it's a huge step backwards
because this law has really been made
for these types of animals the ones that
are not controlled at the health level
the Bill's already exposed divisions
between the countryside and the city
when Spain's ruling socialists drafted
it last year they angered many voters in
rural areas an important support base
in December they submitted a last-minute
Amendment excluding hunting dogs and
other animals involved in traditional
rural activities
but some involved in hunting say it
generates more than 5 billion dollars a
year in economic activity and argue the
law would still effectively legislate it
out of existence
there's a series of points that go
against our sport for example the
obligation to sterilize or new to
animals my dogs have been bred for 30
years raised at their grandmothers and
great-grandmother's house their dogs
with an exceptional genealogy now what
are we supposed to do new to them
but at the weekend thousands marched in
Madrid calling for the law to be
toughened up
I believe animals should not be
exploited animals have to be free and
happy and Greyhounds and all hunting
animals have to be sleeping on a sofa
the law would increase fines for animal
abuse to more than two hundred thousand
dollars and impose a possible two-year
jail sentence for the most serious cases
it's already opened up a debate unlikely
to end soon Nadine barber Al Jazeera